so I enjoy great works of art you know
Sistine Chapel of course beautiful I've
hunted the Great Wall I know that the
Great Wall isn't a piece of artwork but
it is a a man-made achievement yeah
be able to keep that we goes out yes Oh
Monica I love it in the museum's and I
love seeing beautiful even albums like a
album like sergeant Pepper's lion
beetles yeah yeah and you know over the
years I haven't really seen great art
until this weekend and I bought tickets
to see a movie called choker and I saw
an actor and that will we do the best
back acting world Wow now just a loose
finish careful baby vision when I walk I
can you okay this is the screen okay
this is the screen right here okay yeah
and when you can act only having this
much of your face in a screen probably
also just think of this still in a split
second so this is this is only on the
screen for a split second Bobby said
this what you see right right this way
okay Bobby right at the end of my right
and this and the acting in this second
I stood up no in the theatre now you
didn't say that no you know what I said
I'll be honest with you I stood up I
said loser look I turned it everyone in
the field item I don't know him Bobby in
fact I told you this earlier when he was
in the bathroom right
my girlfriend's knees from the
Philippines right was in the theater
she's my [ __ ] okay when you we heard
your voice yeah on kalila goes hey did
the knees Bobby no that's just friend
you know a Sudanese super shitty
opportunity for you
it's a big movie you're both be shy my
mom takes me she I went she goes I'm
gonna see the jokesters I'm excited you
know she loves you yeah yeah I'm excited
to see bride like no doubt mom three
hours later she goes oh I didn't see
Bryan we don't get it though like some
guy I was I don't know about my [ __ ] bro
oh yeah launch is over my go sit by the
window
zero we're gonna find the kid oops you
interrupted me yeah now the danger in
that is you don't get a jewel right the
danger in you interrupting me is if you
don't let daddy drop a jewel right now
we all like jewels just bad yeah yeah
people are dying
exactly I'm gonna [ __ ] give you some
hot hot heat if I'm gonna give you a
[ __ ] lasagna of a conversation and
you go because you're now go ahead give
us the hot was Anya's well that's right
oh no it's a Boomer apologize no I'm not
apologizing for Schumer of
now as I forget it now let me [ __ ]
remember what it is and everyone be
silent until I [ __ ] remember what it
is
keep tell the quiet no I cannot remember
no [ __ ] dude those hot lasagnas gone
dude no such lasagnas so good though
yeah I love it
hot though innit oh and Will Sasso just
came back well take it easy
shut up what all right let's start this
podcast too but first first you're gonna
shut up alright okay man no no no no no
first I'm cares bigger yeah it is if we
got you a big old you to shut up
about seven or eight seconds ago and
here's the other thing I know that on
podcasts we talk yeah that's what
podcasting is all about hye-jin how's it
going well it's got the giggles today
hmm hi how are you good yeah I'm will
well went to the wrong studio so he's
really flying I told you to shut the
[ __ ] up and before we get into that and
we discussed that with your audience
whom you know yeah I love and respect
very much yeah yeah so much so that
especially today I almost feel like you
don't deserve them well I'm asking you
for the last time stop talking we're
gonna do a podcast first here today you
and I yeah yeah okay okay all right I'll
tell you what that is okay okay no I'm
not asking you questions I'm gonna tell
you what it is
okay today Bryan Callen huh you're gonna
take a timeout I would ask you not to
speak anymore if it pleases yeah I mean
if we're friends like you say we are we
are friends
known each other a long time shared a
lot of laughs yeah so I'm just gonna ask
you to let me handle this for a second
and what I'm gonna say it is we're
pulling off a podcast first cuz you're
gonna take a time out Brian and this
timeout is gonna be different than any
other timeout that you've ever heard on
a podcast sure someone has to leave
during a podcast take a [ __ ] or it's not
the time for the guest to talk whether
it's not what I'm talking about usually
it's one or two people talking yeah so
you'd probably think that in that you're
not talking then I'll be filling that
space no Brian we're both gonna take it
time and we're gonna think about what we
did to our friend will begin no one
person that got close was you but sound
like a good time Josh I didn't really
end out his store only fine yeah I don't
think I did honestly I got all right you
grew up in America no I was born in
Korea you were born in Korea when I came
here when I was like three oh okay okay
hey boy yeah
come here Jim what y'all want to show
you something but when you sit something
on your chin yeah you ever see oil come
out of one of these things hey you don't
got this in Korea do you know he cool
real career we do a little differently
down here but unique in the chin you
don't take one on your chinny chin chin
it's not no you yes sir bend over chance
Shia LaBeouf had to cheer now to help
him help me put on my boots Jim put on
my boots chin chin goes home he make me
put on his boot
[Applause]
what the Anya he's a boy his parents
like what did he make you do he showed
me his oil stick what he's all your
stick what did he make you do Jim he
making me taste his oil
I believe chin was it you know why
because talking to check American
American I'm gonna show you some let me
take you around town you hungry boy you
like pancakes oh yeah I got the pancake
what time was it that was it's beyond
your lip bumpy yeah baby
no I don't yeah like your thing were you
eating pasta or that a bump up might you
mean our herpes sore not a Herbie you
don't you don't have a sword oh I know
what that is I was doing pull-ups at you
know I trained it Higa Machado's oh
that's right
8 1 2 7 8 1 2 6 Wilshire Boulevard
Beverly Hills if you ever need me that's
why I train now listen to through your
fine talent that's where you find me I
was doing I was doing take that Greco
take downs I'm so ready I can't give me
a little more time sure you want every
time you want don't be the take back for
all the time don't be disrespectful
because when I when I represent my
sensei Higa Machado yep Allen if you
want to make working hello you could
judge it you come on down bro but do me
a favor you come down to 8 1 2 6
well it's your Boulevard okay you come
correct right I'm coming correct cuz I
respect the hell out of him yeah come
correct and fish in front of them huh I
need a little more time I'm gonna pin
you down now all your pants out for any
instructor know what yeah I need more
time piss on no I don't want to get
[ __ ] snap donk
I'm gonna piss on your friend you cuz no
no dude cuz what are you gonna do Oh how
what do you do
knee on belly no it's gonna pin you down
by your national radio don't [ __ ] the
ring so it's not popular Society got a
rape joke but you don't hold me life and
I want a silver just like this you make
your stupid little chicken egg no I
don't have a chicken I get out this big
every hack in this golden shower time
huh
no I'm gonna see what your instructor
Seabees getting your free lessons after
that no more no peeing on the mat sir no
piss on the mill piss pissing on the mat
technology where they can take your
ak-47 your ar-15 they have drones and
everything else so oh yeah
the US Army they can shoot you from
where you can't see the helicopter you
can't see the Allen okay boomer really
good Hey
I know about military [ __ ] liability
I don't like your saying I'm just saying
cuz you're gonna make me I got your new
training boomer but I've been doing
boom-boom boom-boom i'ma I'm gonna
embarrass you in front of your sensei
he's gonna see this you're not going to
get a black belt next week what's the
problem you two on one dude boom-boom
sit down no boomer
no what's this
don't make me roll out now huh so make
me roll out and [ __ ] up the studio
well this heel hook boomer boomer sit
down okay Hey okay boomer that's what I
said I go in
two on one is he teaching you two on one
on the back too yeah did I hey wait
don't worry about what he's teaching me
teach me [ __ ] where I'm very confident
I'm very comfortable yeah yeah boomer
boomer yeah I know you're gonna do
something okay okay okay I'm good you're
good careful now okay see that right
okay do it
good [ __ ] pretty good huh you know I
mean I crazy
no you mean like friends who everyone
yes there's like the dynamic he's
talking about there's lots of just
friends yeah friend group I feel when
I'm getting old before I we used to
always make that joke if I have a friend
I'm definitely want to [ __ ] him as I get
older especially if they're smarter I
know how I joke
yeah as that as they're smart especially
they're smarter I have more friends who
are women yeah that I don't want to
sleep yes yeah
there's that I don't blame you certainly
does David playing with Down's do you
don't [ __ ] fire an update your
birthday want to sock you right in the
mouth but bring it to exile so I'll slip
that punch that's all I do not swing out
Freddie Roach today all I showed me a
video only went tell him to stop did you
say train my boy cuz he's a fighting
thews yes I did I said can you train
Bryan Callen or Todd Feldman and he goes
for you you know I'll do what I'll have
him killed whoa go Freddie no I think
we're off on this now and I say he was
gonna kill both of them if they ever
attempt a box again what no that's no
I'm looking for it I already see me move
that now I showed him the video and he
the Freddie literally went like this no
no no Freddie please don't know I I slit
it but check out top Feldman's jabbing
it no I slipped left right and I'm very
I'm always out of reach I'm not being
I'm not trying to be a dick I'm always
out of reach I showed him Freddie said
bring him in right now and I will knock
both them out to the body I'll fight him
and I put on 16 inch clothes and I'll
move around with you brang seen inch not
familiar 16 inch I mean 16 loves or 16
inch and I will that's a porno all I
would say is this and you're a big
strong guy do me a favor your hands are
up no problem well watch your midsection
okay cool cool cool man I don't like
I'll tell you what bothers me that you
laugh a little bit because
but they what the boys that pile cars
they're there and they're grinding early
yeah that was there yeah I was a super
Lee you should go down ok - my boy Mario
Lopez sure now watch P's and Q's ready
chomping at the bit to get a hold of you
chomping at the bit I hear he actually I
hate C Slater ox waiting for you AC
Slater ya gonna beat you up like you're
screech is that right they'll [ __ ] you
up like your screen how tall is he
what tall don't worry about that my
dad's in there bro how is he gonna get
he lives in there bro how's he gonna get
past my jack let's find out
I got a Viper quick jab yep let's find
out I got a why don't you keep your
stupid head on I double and triple up my
jab that's fine man but I want to see
him because I hear he can actually box
got a nice body on him - he said morals
and I hear he's sparse
that's a muscular kid that's a young
Frank Grillo right there uh yeah am I
wrong no for sure is he his biggest
Frank doll no he's not biggest Frank
uh-huh but he boxes he's got he's gotten
in there and done some real boxing uh
rounds Canelo hey dude I'll say there's
a video that if I had to like let's say
uh let's see this is the movie Lion
Heart had to put money on it yeah and
they're fighting in wild card jim frank
grillo or all right yeah I get my money
up Frank ah that wouldn't make sense
Frank's a dog he's a dog make some
issues he has a wish he's hit that's a
dog yeah um put my money on that dog
with some issues van Heerden said yeah I
have to be careful I have to be careful
with Frank because you know his he'll
get crazy you get crazy you want to get
hit gets hit he stuffed it on steroids
dude you're not maybe blood-red mad you
not made me [ __ ] just oh what that
picture posting there show water
shouldn't do it he's my friend dude she
and her friend she enjoys yeah we go way
back we're close doesn't seem to sting a
little bit now me and Michelle
we laugh we talk a sting a little train
josh what josh josh is right there i
think josh took that picture
mara yeah we're buddies blood-red what
buddies I knew you're not and then what
did you say
en nobody says nobody says keep your
liver-spotted hands off her bra
hey karate hottie I'll slap around for
you and Josh say the word fam and she
put let us go meaning kill him look at
my face dude she did she actually text
me because we're friends she went
could you please kill count on Monday I
went yes yeah and that's his Josh now
because I said don't be ridiculous I
fell to my knees and I was like how
gorgeous is she though she's so gorgeous
she's also awesome like I said to her
I'm a person I said okay let me get this
right and her daughter's adorable
daughters eight years old so she does
everything on a high level and she's a
superhero Brian she's a superhero mom
mom on a high level wife on a high level
great relationship with with her husband
Josh who's a great guy and then she's a
[ __ ] high level fighter I was like I
said where I go I you need to be the one
that women are looking to like I feel
like they all do where they go oh my god
I love you he's 60 did a whole thing on
okay yeah yeah I just feel like that's
you up for a hot SEC your hot second -
you trained with us didn't train with
her okay yeah and this isn't a sexist
thing but when we would all be rolling
when to go right
well I can't no - faked an injury he
would - pretty also you do big
well-known big I can roll small baby -
pretty - pretty you're pretty here in
tights yeah hot as [ __ ] oh she said
she's in tights I'm in 3016 she's she
smoke show yes Mike her pictures gonna
do her job I'm talking she's pretty in
on Instagram in person smoke she take a
superhero Mike Emilia was you'd come
around
yeah go ah I'd either faking injuries
yeah I just can't
yep well when we we went for lunch and
my my buddy who opened for me he didn't
he had never seen her in she was wearing
these tights is he from a workout Garret
he kind of went he went like this a star
and he went like he made that noise his
name that's his name Josh Josh keep your
[ __ ] stupid peepers off my girl bro
don't worry because her husband punched
in the face
Josh runs her business he also has
another business but he he was an
Olympic he was he was in an Olympic
level boxer I didn't go to the Olympics
but I think was a representing you
national team and stuff like that what
no he was in the Olympics no he'll say
himself he was on the nest she said he
was on limpy's level yeah something like
that and she said and he said he's very
modest he goes no I was not only pick I
wasn't even close you know he says that
but she was like [ __ ] fuse on the
team but anyway yeah anyways food
bottles keep your [ __ ] hands off of
her that well this is work very close
now and so you'd be quiet i went trained
at jackson wank isn't she great I went
rain which accent with the maniac that
guy Frank Lester main he handle him he
wasn't there when he was in the Ultimate
Fighter he lost his front teeth in the
in the fight but he was [ __ ] up see
for a little bit
he's eat trees uh Jon Jones and Mike
Perry's part Spartan Park all his their
speaker and asked him to explain his
[ __ ] college his call it asked him at
college days see about this college
today we just check it up on the pier
says we want to make sure this yeah we
don't believe that you winner incident
no ask him if his dad paid for him to
get into New York communities wart
stressed out that they're gonna find his
dad paid for his degree to get in there
if you pay for his SAT scores uh hey
Christ don't be stuck you're on the
podcast right now don't be a dick don't
say so don't do that
listen I want to ask you a question I
were looking at your Wikipedia page I'm
here with Eric Griffin I'm with Brendan
Schaub yeah yeah I know you know those
guys okay do I turn into a racial thing
alright listen dude it says here that
you attended New York University now
obviously we know you can hold on
because there you go we know you didn't
have the grades to get in so are you
nervous that they're gonna find out your
dad paid and bribed your way into the
college you think you're gonna be caught
up in the scandal why because I didn't
have the grades
I went in and I did a monologue and they
threw their hands up and they said
there's nothing we can do to keep them
out
listen dude I have trouble believing
that so you attended New York University
in there the theatre department I don't
do it I don't know I mean I don't know
okay all right fine I guess our burns
belly fat now I'm not gonna take it but
why don't you want to take my you don't
get rid of that nut sack underneath your
chin what you like the throat scrotum
you don't wanna get rid of left I'm
sorry I'm sorry get same punch
I've been insecure about that for the
past month yeah I know you have this is
do I have that now I mean I don't your
throat looks like my grandma Oh
oh my god but back to do you think you
want do you want to inject an ax bar
right I am NOT talking about anything
else yeah
has this been like in your head for a
while ready to go take my wheels up but
I do now my wheels are getting the
kitchen bro
dig in there oh I keep my chin down yeah
I know you take just like this really
[ __ ] a man daddy knows what's up bro
ain't too long dawg
talking about aliens they 1c the [ __ ]
area 51 dude on Rogen I didn't you
haven't seen it no what's his name his
name's Laser laser Oblast at me cuz if
anyone needs to see it you need sliders
[ __ ] why aliens are real bro I was just
watching listening I know that's
watching I know everything on Netflix
like I know I'm usually the anti
conspiracy guy but you know what I've
looked into it Hunter and Eddie's kind
of right
I'm not just trying to fist you not
threatening okay I'm threatening you
right
what what I swear to God
what [ __ ] aliens are real they are bad
the real good are you are you kneeling
are real I don't think there's any heavy
dolls you [ __ ] okay take it easy [ __ ] do
you stay there's no evidence Hey ah this
Bob laser worked on you after you're
getting.i calm laser okay columns way
cool aliens you should be called no
laser right laser you butcher every name
but lasers well like so laser Laser
believes no no not believe dude he was
laser out there was brought there worked
on nine different UFOs we have video he
worked on nine different nine of them at
area 51 dude if you discredit laser i'ma
[ __ ] you up I just feel like once see
you okay I just feel like I just wanna
say one thing is it possible that he is
a liar why would you why would mr. [ __ ]
do you believe a guy that cleans his
nails with a [ __ ] knife and scribe
several because I was trying I mean
reals trying to warn this guy actually
worked with UFOs on a very secured area
51 guys where's the EV granny I wanted
you to educate yourself before you do
there are aliens are real aliens are
real I would bet my bottom hell you made
contact with us they sure have sorry Han
on earth yeah have we have there's one
space nine of them nine what did you do
right once you grab your phone real
quick your iPhone I mean you don't
believe in a you sound like this guy who
put a bomb in the [ __ ] and the I
sound like an educated human believe in
eight are you have your hat off and why
are you pointing it at me just relax
supreme expensive okay dude you don't
believe in aliens I don't know about
aliens but I don't know that we have
nine spaceships all right I I would love
that what you think we're in here he
said he worked on him what did he do on
anime soup them up I'm asking I'm asking
questions drive me crazy bro
I don't know can I tell you a story real
quick yes he's just real quick please so
chris d'elia is on the road
right he's opening for me and we get to
this one town every city that we go to
we're the funniest guys there yeah
anywhere we go to a coffee bean we go to
a Panera Bread were the plenty of people
to walk in we get to this town
funny Posse it's it's called I think
it's called Dayton Ohio I think I'm
pretty sure you behind there we got a
date and all of us so we're not the
funny people everywhere we go the Panera
we go to a [ __ ] some restaurant and
everyone's odd everything everything is
a lot so Chris and I go to the room and
we start laughing and we're like dude
you know what this town is the
government that built this town because
this is where they breed aliens and then
they breed them here and then they ship
them out into the regular world after
they work here like they work with them
here to deal with like people that are
transient coming through and dealing
with regular humans right we were laughs
and we're dying so hard at this theory
right so the guy that comes and picks us
up for the for the show he's driving us
to the to the to the show and and then
chris is sitting in the front seat I'm
sitting in the back and I go hey my man
um are there any aliens or spaceship set
that uh fly around here and we just we
giggle to ourselves Chris and I are
laughing to ourselves right and the guy
goes yeah uh roswall crashes here the
the spaceship from Roswell Roswell right
Roswell Roswell the Roswell spaceship is
here and it's in hangar let's check this
out he goes chin you you and you're on
the alien train as well I've always kind
of believed that this part of the story
he goes the Roswell crash is here it's
in hangar like 52 you can look at hangar
18 hangar 18 I swear to god Chris and I
we were laughing all day all day we were
laughing when this guy said this Chris
night we look [ __ ] ghost face we look
at each other like what those other
images Brian you don't think it's inbred
leadership this is a real hangar in
Dayton Ohio that looks like a hangar now
listen let's loosen no we were joking
around about this whole alien [ __ ] that
guy said that to us it freaked us the
[ __ ] out because that's literally how
that town felt it felt like they were
like breeding of human
I'm just saying it will show inside
there might be a roof oh all right well
that's my story ask Chris crystal right
there hold on B I'm telling you gotta
listen to this Bob laser last time I got
an a street fight with a bunch of
[ __ ] dudes in Hoboken New Jersey I
don't think so Wow
I'm walking with my girl Kelly and shout
out to Kelly Kelly and housekey Kapowski
Leto nope nope but she's Slater
nope nope no Kelly Slater the surfer who
I was back when she was a girl and I'm
in Hoboken New Jersey walking after
dinner and three young ruffians let's
call him
they were probably I was 23 and they
were 18 maybe even 17 maybe 14 no nope
but they were they were older I'll tell
you why I know that so the guy goes the
guy goes now [ __ ] your girl and I think
I go mmm can't have that
wait we guys just walking by yeah in
this red mouth [ __ ] yo girl I stop and I
turn ha no dude [ __ ] your girl for me
again let me figure out that message go
[ __ ] your girl that's tough one more
time
nah [ __ ] you go mmm they were not black
Italian they were probably Hispanic
probably Puerto Rican as they would say
on the streets
whops yeah no that's the racial term
wapis you know what that stands for
that's what you call an Italian and that
was that was it was a derogatory term
because it mean it meant without papers
so if you came from Italy or a walk yeah
like my family my immigrant family they
didn't have papers almost calling
Mexican aliens
yeah but it was kind of worse back then
Kong Italians
so they cared I heard it in what's the
movie where a young kid of Bronx yeah a
Brock Scottsdale yeah they call him this
if you said that to my grandfather who
was Sicilian he'd lose his [ __ ] mind
out on you knows it was very very so
drivin so these kids were wops or no
they were not they were they were of
Puerto Rican descent okay
what's a derogatory term for report
I mean you know they I don't know Rican
I don't know what they are Eakins
awesome yeah yeah I mean the Puerto
Ricans have a lot of pride and in New
York there's a there's a lot of like a
lot of them were tokens came over in the
50s for jobs or Puerto Rico and then the
manufacturing jobs left for the south so
there was a huge Porto Rican population
it didn't have the ability to work so
then you had you know kids that were
living in projects and then you know
trouble ensued and stuff but but there's
a lot of pride like a lot of Puerto
Ricans every great prideful like hot
girl Porto real I'm on the favorites
some of my famous a my fav back the
story of those most beautiful Ricans
were a chirpin I think they might have
imported reading them but you know but
then again you know there could be a mix
of things but anyway so by the way their
kids and and I come back I turn around
and I go what did you say about my girl
and he goes I would say anybody girl man
he's looking down he goes yes I go
alright and I walk in he goes but I'll
[ __ ] your girl now I turn back around I
go you're talking to me now and he goes
whatever shoes move on move on shoes on
shoes I had a pair of black shoes and
back then I would always wear black
shoes and I preferred with the
steel-toed boot steel toe and soles I
could get to the dragon on they know the
rear toe so I could kick I was Taekwondo
guy remember ok wrestler cyclone ok I
know you laugh but this is my street
friends you go much well dude I'm not
big see what happens is I'm cute go you
understand I'm a hothead because what he
told you shoes they thought these black
boots
yeah there were shoes they weren't even
boots of armor their shoes so anyway I
think they were like they were like Doc
Martens but not Doc Martens because I
didn't like Doc Martens because skin had
worse time blah blah so anyway so uh he
calls me shoes and then I kicked him my
kid him I tried to kick him in the face
they're a hothead man kind of man shoes
babes hi-yah well they're no no cuz
you're saying I'm gonna [ __ ] your girl I
know but that's
today's move on shoes and then and then
I I kicked I knew he was [ __ ] with me
because he was talking my girl and I
kicked him in the face I didn't quite
hit him in the face I think I hit him in
the shoulder long story short he jumps
on me and grabs me around the waist and
now I'm punching him in the head can't
hurt him yeah I can't hurt him Nolan
Ryan stuff yeah but I'm not hurting him
I'm hitting him and and then his two
buddies are circling me but they're not
hitting in weird one kid tries to hit me
I kind of duck it's very awkward
nobody's tough here okay I think of [ __ ]
fest it's a [ __ ] fest to Sesame Street
now a woman a girl who's one of their
friends come over to us I remember to
never forget it she goes how old are you
how old do you sir as I'm beating these
kids up okay but they're 18 so [ __ ] I
don't think they when I'm trying to
Kathleen word there were 13 but you were
they were up they were both my size my
two kids were taller guy so much usual
switch to the Puerto Rican long story
short and now now I'm trying to punch
this guy I'm kidding I can't hurt him
you know the kids off I can't hurt him a
cop comes running up I get away from the
kid I get away from the kid throw
another kick and I wasn't old I was 23 I
didn't say sick ass I didn't got sick I
take that math little Ricans I do what
is this I think I can't do it right now
I wasn't old I was a young tight skin
vampire two weeks ago sir about three
weeks ago now listen so long story short
nobody gets hurt the cop comes running
up because who's fighting well I know
but when the cop came running up I moved
and I bounced off him and he goes who's
fighting and I go those guys grabbed my
girl ran away now here's what's great
about the story here's what's how [ __ ]
up I am I'm so angry we went back and
got a gun
that old bride goes gets in his car I
had an Acura white Acura all bride gets
in his car and I get a [ __ ] stick
I had an axe handle
I had an ax handle I Hickory ax handle
cuz I saw it in a movie somewhere
somebody show talk about hair cream and
now I'm driving around looking for these
[ __ ] guys cuz I'm gonna I'm gonna hit
him as hard as I can and in the head
that's how crazy I was never ran into
all the Liam Neeson story when you
search him for black I know you're
searching for no that's not true
never found him for a week a week that's
how I growl moms huh I had wrong
problems I probably still you'd be noise
sale problems I get I guess she's oh I
agree
injustice guy felt like they were being
rapists or something I had they were
they just gradually talking on my foot
no no they were doing it they were doing
it to me at my girl it wasn't I it was
rapey it was rapey you know me I love
everybody you know me if I'm your but if
I'm matter - yeah but I'm also doing the
Lord's work in that situation
Donaire cakes isn't the Lord's work i
grazed him was like wow but you have to
not go see gay I'm gonna leave now
because this is embarrassing it was yeah
I didn't really yeah [ __ ] wasn't that
impressive no I felt can I be honest I
remember this the other thing I felt
weak it just didn't feel strong I
couldn't get him off me and if those
other guys tried it I just it was a
couple of 14 year olds no no they were
18 you got it they were poor Rican stuff
tell age - well yeah they had full
beards but no pubes um cuz they were
naked oh you guys tried the popeyes
chicken salad my brother would you talk
to Jay about it no but I can't wait I
mean listen how fat my brother Jay is
although he's losing weight too but I
was his cheat day he said he went to
chick-fil-a for lunch then drove home
went to [ __ ] Popeyes and bought the
chicken sandwich to compare the two
that's a good which is better he said
Popeye yeah and I responded back you're
dead to me that's how much I love
chick-fil-a no I can't believe neither
of you have tried it I want it no idea
we're talking prior to bring it in
I'm actually you can't have a dog I'm
not sure I'll get out no you haven't
brain no just came now I always never
had Popeyes cuz I went to college down
in DC you sold
oh it just came out right chicken sounds
just came out take it easy now
wait come back you're old no please come
back right please come back I'm sorry
I'll be younger
Brendon I'll be younger I'll be okay
okay oh no I've actually had Paul I went
to school in DC in 1914 okay now Popeyes
just create a [ __ ] chicken hey man
I'm sorry
god I'm sorry dude
oh no this is my bit well I've actually
had both no you know I hate Chinese yeah
yeah we all have two pickles on it yes
man to come with pickles you via that
looks there's no way this is nothing
chick-fil-a don't know - that looks
super tasty that's the word that it's
very it's better than everything I'll
[ __ ] go get it now there's like who
should maybe should bring it on
Wednesday
I also thinking of bringing it in yeah
but it's got to be hot that's another
thing I just get it I'll be so fine hey
I bet chick-fil-a cold or hot delicious
oh we had to try that that Burger King
burger that had been made like six days
ago yeah it's not yeah I did taste a
flame right there we had breaking of the
sponsors out how many burking you I - I
eat the [ __ ] out of Zach all right
where's anymore inertial look at the
head person I guess that's chilly right
here fat-ass - that's a real comparison
I don't give a [ __ ] do chick-fil-a is so
don't gotta make no gangster chick-fil-a
is they they have a giant shop they have
a giant restaurant in the arena in
Atlanta they're not even open on Sundays
Sunday [ __ ] they're religious yeah
get over that though yeah I take the
Lord's Day off bro they take wow that
Popeye chicken salad looks pretty good
or he can't believe neither one of you
had it we could have [ __ ]
you're on a plan for Wednesday we could
do Wednesday but what we should do is
have a chick-fil-a and a Popeyes and
then we all judge which one's the best
but just get it right away I know it's
gonna be tough
well the closest Popeyes is about seven
and a half miles away so it's
not gonna be that fresh listen I don't
need it I don't need it that fresh you
taste a good family also does pop I do
fries do you have the waffle cut fries
you know seasoned fries not watering cut
though come on Brendan yeah but now that
occur it looks so good
yeah but that look at the first of all I
know that doctored up picking find out
right that some kids picture how about
here
again that's them [ __ ] on
chick-fil-a my price everybody knows
chick-fil-a does the best that bun does
look [ __ ] fresh though yeah and they
said it's like a cucumber type of pickle
you know like pickles are usually pickle
but it's like fresher like a coupon yeah
yeah I can't believe how we've had it
and what you been doing this I saw it I
saw this that I had to make a cheese now
at home cuz I wanted to eat something
close to yeah I didn't want to add rival
I heard is that there's like they're
running out in certain places there's
the lines are like you know the chickens
and coachup what they don't have the
chicken sandwich on there I try o type
move cat because that's what I would
have done I figure the Nerds you you
never seen that movie oh yeah oh because
of that I [ __ ] up putting a condom on
for the first time yeah do you remember
when they you really got to know this
movie I watch this movie a lot but they
walk the two nerds in the Alfa's do the
Alpha omegas and they see two sheep
there and they go gentlemen and they go
like this with condoms and they roll out
they like oh yeah I had I'm unrolled and
they just went blink and I went oh so
the first time I put on a condom I go
you gotta roll it like Revenge of the
Nerds or the way my mom rolls my socks
up she was all rolled up so I unrolled
it thinking that's how you put on a
condom I never put ID on him before I'm
17 years old
I scoot a slide it on my push it over
airs trapped in the side of it and as I
push it just inflates uh-huh and I'm
like trying to squeeze the air out of it
like I'm making a balloon animal and so
I [ __ ] ruin that condom there's a
first time I tried to poke on tomales do
girl yeah I know of course I remember
yeah
do you hear dating or was it a one
night's dating dating so I go out to
Jeff Hartley he's in the living room or
Pet Sematary he's with his girl we had
two condoms we got a member sixteen
seventeen years old we got him into
exile on the corner dale mabry and
Erlich so I go over shot the Exxon so I
go over I go hey man I need that I need
that other condom and he's like you
already did it and I go his long story
bless him and he was like all right so I
grabbed it and then words like reservoir
tip into the reservoir tip make sense to
me I know yeah roll it over even putting
it off felt good I was like woo I
thought I always felt weird
oh-hoh was the first kind of my better
put on in my life other than the one
where I made the balloon animals so then
I get on top of her real time one done
that's right done one pump one pump
that's I meant done oh wow doggy
of course caught me so off hardy man hey
you premature ejaculation now Oh bro I
did all through my 20s what bob was she
like what she looked at me dead serious
looks at the mother look on my face and
goes are you gonna put it in oh I missed
her vagina
I [ __ ] between her butt cheek in the
bed and came I didn't [ __ ] [ __ ] a
man and you came and then I had to [ __ ]
her deal with a compromise okay here's
like going on a hike going hey why don't
you get those dry socks and shoes jump
in the river real quick yeah dicks
barely well at that age you're good to
go my first time you never [ __ ] with a
condom let my me under like Jack you
were never on a big condom where were
you still not there for [ __ ] so come
on come on what we doing syphilis bring
it in my yeah
Oh 5t on that I even think if I had my
first gay experience I'd be like bro
you're putting on a condom like these
for all you got a [ __ ] movie that raw
dog me yeah dude Rob you like that I'm
getting [ __ ] in his game I just rolled
on Bolivia's I was like we're all dog me
bro
I want to be infected that was
impressive that was impressive look with
your attack the condom I couldn't feel
anything so I lasted forever oh it was
it was so uncomfortable she was dry it
was a nightmare
Oh nightmare no not not a good
experience now nightmares and there's
dad walked in on us
oh no yeah really yeah and he was drunks
I didn't realize what was going on he
was like hey the new year ball all right
you guys tired you can close the door
I'm like tired I'm balls deep in your
daughter here sir [ __ ] what would you do
that say you guys must be tired she went
quietly I got stiff then he left she was
like oh my god I'm like anyway was not
very romantic was not very poor Noah
[ __ ] was off oh yeah where's my camera
and that's and that's why I'm in a
restaurant in Vegas right your sister
runs right Joe yeah just stop yeah not a
time for you I'm just trying to get you
a Rolex but what am i what are you doing
it's a fake laughing see if you're doing
hi I'm successful and so is he
not so much hey what the [ __ ] Joe just
saying this is my play sure and you're
showing up a news clip wearing my
sweatshirt you're trying to promote your
brand with my just workout that's a
final warning news that's promise you
mere sweat yes that's a [ __ ] Russell
Athletic so gotta forget take it back -
I'm not taking it back right now got it
you can't even fix that in the color
code what are you trying to adjust the
color
[ __ ] gray [ __ ] you [ __ ] great what's not
great tix brings out my eyes you don't
have eyes for success roasted oh what's
your [ __ ] restaurant so I can not go
dropped it's a registry job yeah it's a
mister what do I serve you to P that
Philippine no I sir it's Japanese it's
like if you had to come up with a and I
think you said this before maybe on
interviews if you had to come up with a
sound effect for what I do the prouds
okay that's copyrighted that's copyright
stuff it is covering because because it
sucks and you know why it sucks why dude
it's [ __ ] so annoying dude let me put
my sunglasses
look dude all right I [ __ ] saw him on
the phone my agents were talking about
deals obviously I got stuff coming in we
got the [ __ ] guys in the lab quotes
are like never seen anything like this
we've got deal after deal and they go
like that and they're like and they come
up to me and he's like um somebody get a
bucket yeah and he's like we have
another deal for you mister D'Elia and
he pissed
he pissed again his pants are yellow at
this point right from all the pissing
he's doing because he's nervous he's my
fan yeah so so he goes like this this is
I'm talking about all this [ __ ] I mean
and you go like this Chris I say yeah
and and I'm on I'm on a conference call
at this point right and mine I hear
click click and I say guys and one agent
left
he says Chris I said what I said what
would all this clicks and he said the
rest of the agents they had they hung up
and I said before and they said they
don't want to be on the phone for this
part and I said why what's going on you
know you're making me nervous you're
making me anxious yeah it was like this
I'm anxious hearing this I've tried to
stop this and I said stop what dude just
lay it to me straight man what's going
on
am I getting cancelled and he says no I
said well what is it man and he said
they're making a documentary about your
shoulder I just said leaving that they
would do this why would the [ __ ] would
they do that and they go like that they
say because they're just getting out of
control no go like this my aging says
No so go on they're just they're just
getting to get out of control and I said
what
and he said they said what's the endgame
here Chris do you want them to be higher
than your head I said I don't know you
know I just keep doing the circuit
training and the [ __ ] bodybuilding
and they said they say well we can't
stop the documentary and the guys are
coming and then I said really calmly I
said that's it call okay
and careful yeah yeah and he go and I
hear click and I said what the [ __ ] did
the last agent hang up no no no that you
hung up oh and I saw now I'm alone yeah
like a lone on this [ __ ] conference
call and then I hear Chris and I say
yeah and he says I was here all along
and it's my other agent I was like you
didn't hang up he's like no I got back
on because I knew the other agent didn't
want to tell you this yeah so I got back
on and I gotta tell you and I said what
is it called and he goes like this
long sigh he goes boom that's that's
that um the last click was me
yeah the last click was me I wasn't
happy I know yeah so I'm looking forward
to your documentary I'm not Bob boom I'm
not dude yeah I had to [ __ ] run from
my car to here because of the [ __ ]
cameras well I'm not even using they're
using that old 90s cameras that are
because they want to be obnoxious and in
my face about it I am and I appreciate
that and I look forward to you about the
drink we're regressing with your style
we're going back to jeans sandals no no
I I it's just hot today and I threw them
on in a hurry that's all I won't wear
pants with sandals in my house really
nope got to get the mail like that
we're not Burke's you go Burt no you
know that's good she put out a line he
wouldn't he bought a pair of boots with
a buckle on him from Gucci never warm
again you warm once I think right I wear
them all the time
you two if ever I'm not wear boots this
do I wear mother really yeah I love
those boots have you ever tried Burke's
Birkenstock oh you got a Burke
to wait for me nice top oh you got a
Burke coming from me dude is different
it's not like flip-flops it's not like
slides
it's bird that's wide open it's like a
combination everybody's got double
straps you actually feel you could do
something you could like you could fight
if you need like real you know it's
clear what can you run the new me to yes
birds comments dude is a communist why
are those Burke's five huh
340 [ __ ] they're made to your foot nah
man I don't do dance sandals just so no
no that's not saying that's how you got
to stop
that's Burke's that's the difference
that guy looks pretty cool hey Bryce you
never is right there aren't you man
right there killin it that's it that be
dude that's refined what are you gonna
wear if you know there's a bird inside
there's a Birkenstock store on a bikini
hey hey
so get them let's get you to my ears my
Tevas but don't wear though yeah I think
you can you're past that you're more
refined than that yeah you're a Berk
you're you know you're better than that
yeah you lose me yeah but you could Berk
that's the thing that you don't realize
you can Burke and my toes dog is
different it's your toes already
vulnerable and you start not vulnerable
summer's over bro look I'm in the ledge
look ugly the ledge protects your toe
you see at the front there's that little
ledge you're not stubbing your toe not
even one time there are not even one
time you stubbing your toe and your heel
there's that little hook right there
that's day look like Jesus shoes yeah
say what it look like Jesus hey soos in
an emergency really maybe but that is
you never have another sex it's a
different life there's this Fight Club
hey can I say something this is taric's
gym yep can I say some what's up my
heart don't you know those shirts can I
say side train on this channel hey I'm
gonna dump in your mouth can I say
something god man well we're shooting
yesterday with our friend Aubrey Marcus
the Restonic crew at the twins shout to
the twins ASU tigers shouting it's big
the twins the big Victor twins you would
not shut the [ __ ] up about going to
special salons house I'm talking dude
I'm just friends you what you would have
thought Brian was a 91 year old you ask
me what I did kept showing week I do
know in any time I bike no sly post any
time I'd say anything hey called
Sylvester bro sorry's a friend of mine
Oh mr. Xylon he's very slight posted a
video look I'm a beef did I hang out at
his house with Arnold Schwarzenegger and
Al Pacino and and Dolph Lundgren yeah
did I not some other people yeah was I
was Sly Stallone sure
now did his living room smell like
testosterone and protein parts and death
uh-huh the I tell you so with the one
thing about him over anything else what
was the one thing that surprised me he's
[ __ ] hilarious
he's [ __ ] hilarious like he's got the
best sense of humor which I never knew I
didn't know he loved his nut um what
else I know but he tells stories and I
was like I said to Frank Grillo I go
dude he's [ __ ] hilarious because I
know he's got a great sense of humor he
tells [ __ ] hilarious stories so that
was really cool and you guys were over
there
to watch the fights yes and do they do
they like you if the unboxing the new
[ __ ] yes Arnold was of course there
was in the other in the in the other
room the screening room watching the UFC
we were watching the boxing but they had
the wave for the boxing who they will
have the UFC was done but in anyway so
we were running back and forth and then
we you know but it was just really
interesting I will
say this as well such as the funniest oh
yeah wait the video and then other ones
uses common plan shows this this is me
and Frank grilling over Al Pacino now
please read Will Sasso scammy Oh Brian
Connors more screen time in this
Instagram post than he does like [ __ ]
Cowan come on yeah
let's let's bring it down for a second -
hold on URIs Gary Gary give it all no
not no not us yeah no I need you bro
listen listen you're bad guy Brian I'm a
bad guy all the guys I remember I never
talked you to marry me I hear some
waitress passing kind of says you were
difficult at one point God knows I came
in what she said and I come on the
podcast Howard Gary Owen is difficult
and that is so good that I heard you
heard it he's a good you heard you were
like what the [ __ ] right and I was like
I didn't mean it backpedal don't
apologize I've heard nothing but great
things about you and and I want to say I
want to say you remember who said the
bad thing about me I remember her was it
brandy brandy and Pittsburgh granted the
sacred bra I want a single mom a single
mom always got an ad she said you struck
her you struck her and [ __ ] a black pot
right yeah the club open her banger
banger as well and then you took a [ __ ]
in the middle of the floor and said [ __ ]
you guys and you left so that would
answer the checks I guess we're
difficult so that's all I heard that's
all I heard that's all I heard other
than that
I hear you're a fantastic guy I think if
we didn't tip he ordered like primary
taquitos all weekend that must have been
a sense yeah honestly when I first
started doing stand-up I had no concept
of tipping really I didn't realize it
means hip your green room wait
so when when I held all you guys I was
like this I bet you this goes way back
on tip and greenroom waitress days weird
it's [ __ ] how much she was
advertising
how many fee ma hundreds and hundred
thousand yeah how's that you've done and
then one waitress waitress had a bad day
and you rat him out of millions well
here's the thing I threw a little bit of
a tantrum on my set the other day I felt
justified but I guarantee I guarantee
the people that didn't know what was
going on
looked at me and said that guy's a dick
all the room and so we've all had these
moments even though I give a lot and I'm
a comedy Jasmine you knew it you are a
bit of a diva I could be a dick I just
get mad I just I throw a little tantrum
so you're not at anybody but you're a
dick the last week of March yeah
not that I remember the date come on the
pod cuz I'm sorry the amazing thing is
like you look at your whole career like
okay I think I've done some decent
things in my career and the only time
Brian counter brought me up quiz is
you're difficult to work with what a
dick move all this it was such I was
more taken back that we did a movie
together and you had no concept that
person I'm a [ __ ] never think I'd ever go
to work with I go we didn't say that on
ride-alongs you were fine that day
you're a marine no my baby maybe maybe
still here I was like the guy's a
veteran the whole thing was shitty III
couldn't backtracked more I could the
back pedaled more I did film it's unlike
you to go Babylon it's always like
really bad it's but especially publicly
on a podcast it just I was just talking
one month about that guy yes Gary are
like volatile that's he said yeah he's
Reval at all
that's what I remember but that by the
way is not what the person said so I
made that up I was like he must have
thought my character right along was
real oh my god off my clothes I'm a bad
guy well I like you guys now we have you
here now yeah yeah I'm all the way from
Nick Waldron Cowell man and crushed me
Adam oh that's I meant eight how about
yesterday me my dad wanted that hike I
usually run it but I walked with you man
six miles
you went with me jog yeah yeah but where
we hiked at is where Kanye does his
weird service and so we tried going
through this one way there's security
everywhere am I do you know my dad's
always like what the [ __ ] is this I'm
like we might have to cut this way it
took me longer you know we're not
cutting anything we're gonna go through
here so the security is okay you can't
come through my death like the [ __ ] we
can path does this way our car is that
way the kensic all right sir and so
we're going that way but there's
security everywhere he does like this
weird service on staff coach or what
looks like a [ __ ] cult all his people
aren't like just normal people and white
like Clint and they all have [ __ ]
Yeezys on it so that's that that's that
old-school Baptist [ __ ] where you you
all dress in white and then you get
baptized there might be a baptism no no
no no I'm telling you I see it all the
time what's he [ __ ] matter just
having fun that go that picture right
there which one this one the one down
right there that's right hike that's him
that's him and his do you know that was
him I saw that on Instagram I said I
thought that was excites LA two men and
security rude and there's like Bentley's
and [ __ ] Rolls Royces and and so usik
thing or what is oh it's a Sunday Gospel
Church okay there is an ivory diving
I've been to Sunday Gospel Church in
Harlem there's a pastor there yeah I've
been I've been not only have I been to
Sunday Gospel Church in Harlem I've also
been to a funeral of my friend's mom in
Harlem because she grew up in Harlem and
he did to the idea that did a musician
get on and create be 100% a musician go
under I heard the Deacon everybody this
singing was unbelievable he goes now all
of me it wasn't a sad woman so I don't
want to see a long long faces in here I
want to see some I want to see some
music I want to celebrate her life
and they got into some singing that I
was just like this is the greatest thing
I've ever [ __ ] seen in my life it was
the greatest thing there you got to come
down that is why the music came from
that's where a lot of I don't know how
suit like DMX came to this well he's a
preacher but they all a lot of them
learn how to sing in the church Whitney
Houston learn how to sing in the church
Katy Perry learns thing the church
showed it [ __ ] Aretha Franklin all
jacks how to sing the list goes on and
on yeah so you know I'm joining the
black church it does look fun I said
it's weird there's like security and
then all these kanye west side
oh dude outside on top of the mountain
where everyone's hiking kind of like
that cuz he's preaching from the sermon
he's preaching these on from the
mountaintop sermon about yeah you don't
know [ __ ] about Christian is a little
strange going to hell anyway people
thought yeah there are white people
there okay I know I was worried do I put
my shirt on it's a hike with my shirt
off one put my shirt on so I don't scare
everybody yeah just a giant guy with
tats yeah be mmm yeah this this Gracie
tattoo looks a little a little bit like
hey you see a giant a on a guy can
what's going on he in an order there it
is
God play that let me see it hopefully
see me and my pop in the background
[Music]
that's really an excuse to jam it's so
cool though is it yeah I think so yeah
all I think it's learn how to fit be
musicians why find it subversive like
very cult-like you know it's weird to me
is like the grown people in the Yeezys
alright yeah that's awesome that's so
good it's like mmm
that wasn't cutting us would you be
saying that police are outside and doing
some positive though yeah there you go
so cute though well mmm cuz I'm joining
that church today we can join how can I
get in show up in a white robe
so most people look like this yeah
that's never happening I'm never getting
and I'm never putting that stuff well
then he can't be in it yeah well that's
how like yeah I did some batting I'm
dissing batting I hit a baseball
that came out okay yeah it was a 60-mile
say I did some batting having a cage
it's a batting cage the ball is at 60
miles an hour
daddy connected I was surprised my bad
speed I have it on video it's so slow
it's depressing I should send it to you
so you can see how slow 16 yeah the only
reason I was able to hit it I'm done
that tonight was so 60 would be my
little school level yeah it's the wall
it's 14 years old yeah middle school and
and I could hit it only cuz I play
tennis - the ball comes over that way 60
I can't imagine a tiered now you didn't
turn it up higher I could have turned it
to up to 70 but I hurt my [ __ ] hands
I hit up and the vibration killed me I
just said it - okay and it was like ow
[ __ ] so have you won was last time you
were at a batting cage been a while yeah
but we didn't start 60
what you start at well growing up high
speed no and ISO 60 super slow
dude that's middle-school speed so when
you go out daddy hit it well well yeah
yeah 12 year old throwing balls bro no
you
oh you're bragging you get a ball at 50
years old off a 12 yeah oh I'll tell you
this I was at my boys he's got this
high-end gym my buddy Kevin BAE at
hybrid cross phrasing every mad at me
fine hybrid fit fitness whatever is
anyway they treat they train the high
school kids going into college the 18
year olds 17 18 year olds [ __ ] huge
these days oh my god just huge and
strong I was like how does a kid kids 17
what are you talking to us monstrous or
[ __ ] monsters dude I can't believe
you bragged about in this six bring this
up though cuz you're gonna be impressed
give it a few seconds then take me oh
yeah no but it's dude can I be honest no
little practice I'm playing hard pitch
ball maybe dinner I'm saying she joined
a softball league or if I can stop by
laugh at I laugh at that cuz I hit every
time sixty I don't know if you're gonna
throw it is she if you enthrone me throw
junk don't throw down the Packers I'm
gonna hit it you know I'm saying
especially a sixty from a 12 year old
you know what bring it up a couple miles
an hour I don't get off I can't believe
he didn't who was like we'll start at 60
I don't I'm just what if they put it on
because I've never I haven't I haven't
swung a bat since I was literally eight
III litters I just followed watch watch
my tape watch how slow this is
do that so slow I haven't shown dude why
would you sell my oh my god it's so slow
dude I was so depressed I mean me and I
was a little nervous it's all my elbow
should be higher I think oh man they're
good for you - really she gotta get some
exercise
thanks buddy it's cool man dude I'm
hitting no huh I'm connecting hello do
you think I have potential you do man I
think you should look and say it with a
straight face no do it man say it with a
straight leg not bitching see some
connecting mother I I was so depressed I
saw I was like my bat slow slow but I
was probably doing it I was it was slow
because I was tired as time it bad you
brought that up to brag you're lucky
told me the speed too because I would
have made a lot with see she got out the
other exercises oh man looks like Hanks
buddy she pronounced my calories bro
seriously thanks [ __ ] off dude you like
to go to go to one the real fast [ __ ]
ones that the pro is lazy you're not
sniffing it you're not sniff out I
scared old one off and it was a victory
oh yeah freaky let's see laws now or
some [ __ ] hey 80 would be high school
level high school there's kids dropping
nineties bro then the pros let's throw
some junk on it
Oh fine right in sixty no one's throwing
city you want through it some junk on it
you're not
he's the ball or if it comes out here
could he know I'm telling I died it was
I'm talking damn near impossible I was
like oh well how does someone hit this
in the pros yeah and then in the coach I
cuz I was at USC I'm the professional
Madden guys and I went oh my in I went
this how it looks yes yeah but look the
balls heat is gonna come right here
right here Brennan so just trying to
and dude his [ __ ] god I found his cut
him off you didn't in the bad speech
basically right or what you couldn't get
a bat around in time I mean again I've
been bad and forever yeah but I was
connecting but it's just fouling but
then that's after like 30 strikeouts now
imagine them throwing [ __ ] junk at
you chunk I'm I'm hitting it maybe well
that's why maybe one out of ten dude if
you if you're a pro you hit three out of
ten year on the whole thing that's so
crazy aim of lose it yeah it's a game of
like basically gonna be so strong here
and then home run well that's why they
would always give Alex Rodriguez so much
[ __ ] when he's strike out on the
playoffs and stuff and I was like I mean
[ __ ] you guys when Kurt - yo mad bro and
when Curt Schilling a long time ago was
pitching and he would pitch this sinker
or slide or whatever his curveball it
was it would get end up at your feet
dude it's a guy goes the guy goes he was
struck out everybody everybody everybody
and they go what are you gonna do this
is like also Kenner goes what are you
gonna do I can't them hitting baseballs
it's [ __ ] nuts okay at that high
level this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]